BREAKING THROUGH THE RUSSIAN
DEFENSIVE LINES AND TAKING BACK
A LOT OF THEIR TERRITORY.
>> NATASHA BERTRAND REPORTING
FROM WASHINGTON, THANK YOU.
>>> A CALL FOR JUSTICE IN
MEMPHIS, TENNESSEE OVER THE
DEATH OF TYRE NICHOLS.
AT A CITY COUNCIL MEETING,
TENSIONS RUNNING HIGH DEMANDING
FOR THE RELEASE OF THE BODY
CAMERA VIDEO.
HE WAS BEATEN BY OFFICERS FOR
THREE MINUTES ON JANUARY 7th
AFTER THEY STOPPED HIM FOR
RECKLESS DRIVING.
SHIMON PROKUPECZ IS LIVE IN
MEMPHIS THIS MORNING WITH MORE.
SHIMON, GOOD MORNING.
PRELIMINARY RESULTS OF AN
AUTOPSY WERE RELEASED.
WHAT ARE WE LEARNING NOW?
>> Reporter: THE AUTOPSY WAS
DONE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
FAMILY.
THE FAMILY DID THEIR OWN
INDEPENDENT AUTOPSY.
AND WHAT THEY FOUND, ACCORDING
TO THEIR ATTORNEY BEN CRUMB, WAS
THAT TYRE NICHOLS DIED FROM
SEVERE BLEEDING AS A RESULT OF A
BEATING.
DON, I WANT TO TAKE YOU OUT HERE
TO THE SCENE.
THIS IS WHERE IT ALL STARTED.
THIS IS THE INTERSECTION THAT
POLICE SAY THAT TYRE NICHOLS WAS
FIRST STOPPED BY POLICE.
AND THEN HE RAN.
THERE WAS A PURSUIT.
ALONG THIS ROAD HERE.
ALL THE WAY -- JUST ABOUT UNDER
A MILE NEAR WHERE HIS MOTHER
LIVES AND THAT IS WHERE
ULTIMATELY HE WOULD DIE.
WHERE INVESTIGATORS SAY POLICE
CAUGHT UP TO HIM AND THEN
SOMETHING HAPPENED.
AND ACCORDING TO THE FAMILY
WHICH HAS VIEWED BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE, THEY SAY HE WAS BEATEN
IN THAT LOCATION, ULTIMATELY WAS
TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL WHERE HE
DIED.
MOST OF WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED HERE IS NOT COMING FROM
THE POLICE.
THEY HAVE REFUSED TO RELEASE ANY
INFORMATION.
BASIC QUESTIONS TO THE POLICE
ABOUT WERE THESE OFFICERS IN
UNIFORM?
WHAT TIME EXACTLY WAS TYRE
NICHOLS TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL.
ALL THOSE QUESTIONS HAVE
REMAINED UNANSWERED BY THE
POLICE AS WE KNOW FIVE OFFICERS
WERE FIRED, TWO EMTs HERE WERE
PLACED ON LEAVE AS A RESULT OF
THIS INCIDENT.
AND NOW WE WAIT.
WE WAIT FOR THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY TO MAKE HIS DECISION ON
WHETHER OR NOT HE'S GOING TO
PURSUE CHARGES.
AND, OF COURSE, ULTIMATELY THAT
VIDEO.
THE BODY CAMERA FOOTAGE AND
OTHER FOOTAGE THAT POLICE HAVE,
DON.
>> CAN WE TALK ABOUT THAT
EMOTIONAL, FIERY COMMUNITY
MEETING THAT HAPPENED LAST
NIGHT.
WHAT ARE RESIDENTS SAYING ABOUT
THE BODY CAM NOT BEING RELEASED.
THEY WANT IT OUT THERE.
>> Reporter: ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY THEY WANT IT OUT.
THEY WANT MORE INFORMATION
BECAUSE THE POLICE HAVE BEEN
REFUSING TO GIVE ANY
INFORMATION.
SO THEY WANT THE BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE RELEASED.
THEY WANT OTHER INFORMATION
RELEASED.
LISTEN TO SOME OF THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO SPOKE AT A CITY
COUNCIL MEETING.
>> AS YOU KNOW, THERE WAS A
MURDER THAT TOOK PLACE HERE ON
JANUARY THE 7th, I BELIEVE,
MR. TYRE NICHOLS, HE WAS
MURDERED AT THE HANDS OF THE
MEMPHIS POLICE.
I'M VERY UPSET WITH EVERYBODY ON
THIS CITY COUNCIL BECAUSE YOU
ARE OUR REPRESENTATIVES, YOU ARE
OUR CHECKS AND BALANCES.
AND NOT ONE OF YOU HAVE COME OUT
PUBLICALLY AND DEMANDED THAT
THAT TAPE THAT WE PAY
$3 MILLION, CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG, MR. WADE, WHEN WE PAID
FOR THE BODY CAMS, WE THE
TAXPAYERS PAID FOR.
THIS IS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND
DAMNIT WE GONNA HAVE IT OR WE
NEED A REFUND ON OUR TAX DOLLARS
THAT WE PLAY.
THE PUBLIC WANT TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENED.
WE WANT TO KNOW ARE WE REALLY
EMPLOYING PEOPLE THAT THINK IT'S
OKAY TO BEAT THE SHIT OUT OF
FOLKS.
>> WHAT WE HEARD BEFORE, WE PAY
FOR THE CAMERAS, WE WANT TO SEE
WHAT IS GOING ON.
DO I WANT TO SEE THE VIDEO?
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M A MAMA TOO.
SO MANY OF US ARE.
WE'RE BROTHERS, SISTERS, AND
CHILDREN, SONS AND DAUGHTERS.
BUT WHAT WE WANT TO SEE IS
JUSTICE FOR TYRE AND EVERYONE
ELSE LIKE HIM WALKING THESE
STREETS.
>> Reporter: AND SO, DON, NOW
THIS IS ALL IN THE HANDS OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY HERE.
WE'RE WAITING TO HEAR MORE FROM
HIM.
HE SAYS THE VIDEO WILL COME OUT
ONCE HIS INVESTIGATION IS
COMPLETE.
ONCE THEY'RE DONE INTERVIEWING
WITNESSES.
HE SAID THE REASON THEY DON'T
WANT TO RELEASE IS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT TO IN ANY WAY, SWAY
WITNESS TESTIMONY IF THEY SEE
THIS VIDEO, THEY MAY CHANGE
THEIR TESTIMONY AND THAT IS THE
REASON WHY THIS VIDEO HAS NOT
BEEN RELEASED.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU, COMMUNITY
MEMBERS CERTAINLY ARE NOT BUYING
THAT.
THEY WANT THE INFORMATION.
THEY WANT THE TRANSPARENCY THAT
THEY CERTAINLY FEEL THEY'RE NOT
GETTING.
SO NOW, DON, WE WAIT FOR T